there is always a connection in every
household to the steelworks in every
house when you drive home from car
therefore or even Swanzey you can see
the steelworks in the background it's
it's part of Portola
I think will be bested out of the year
because we haven't got anything when we
within the EO we haven't got any better
I think things that got worse
I think that any negative aspects of
leaving will be worth the price that we
pay to get our own way or get some
control back
there's been 1.4 billion pounds of
minimal investment from the EU into this
region and that's included things like
construction projects training and kind
of employability projects and those
kinds of things that have made a big
difference around here
if there's one standout issue that's
different from a Tolbert
it's got to be steel and the fate of the
steel works there's been steelmaking
here since monks were making steel back
in the 1200
they say for every job in the steelworks
there's another fool that rely on the
money from the steelworks over in the
supply chain and things so that's huge
all I've ever seen as a decline in the
steelworks that's all I've ever seen my
name's Andrew Clark I'm from a town
called portal but I've always wanted to
work in the steelworks due to my dad
working there for 30 ideas we've been
recently made redundant I voted to leave
one of my biggest decisions was based
upon what a lot of the older people have
said to me I'm only 30 years of age
before my time we were obviously
independent I think that we can do it
again some of the projects that have
been funded by the EU of things like the
train station where once it was built
you know millions of pounds spent on it
on a much needed actually local facility
great for business you know all of those
things it's a total waste of money it
looks like something from Star Wars
we have stinking duty in there I would
use there
my name is Michele Coleman I woke up
mason's caffee and come over potala best
just waste a lot of money than they they
just building things there was no good
for anything else
no he's fancy statues children for
finally soap using them today they
wouldn't use the clarity of a syllabus
in photographers and they count because
it's not up to sound there but they can
go up late why can they spend money on
that returns got the fifth biggest
economy in the world and I'm sure that
they've taken knocks before and come
back from it we survived two world wars
and gone on to great things
I was born and bred in Portal but in
Marga
I also used to work in the steel works
from 1965 until seven years ago when I
retired
I voted to leave the EU immigration was
top of our concern the fact that we
couldn't stem immigration from people in
the EU on the likelihood of the Middle
East people come in here and Afghans and
Turks it was getting out of hand people
outside of the UK now probably looking
at the UK thinking that we are on a
xenophobic a race system and all these
things that have been banned about right
now of course that's perception it's not
the reality my name is Darren Nichols
I've lived in this area all my life I
was born in in in Neath and lost my
family I live in in Patara in the shadow
of British steel with a country full of
minorities I'm a openly gay man I've
lived in South Wales for all my life
again we're in a dust really loads as
well so where men are men you know and
I've never ever had a problem with my
sexuality here I've I've never felt I've
ever hide it
why you leave first for security and I
believe that the European Union is
creating a super state and it's set to
dissolve the smaller nation-states
within Europe Britain are leaders and
have been leaders in the world and I
think this has taken the lead on
something that for me is after control
it feels quite quite bleak I guess for
people that they don't know what's gonna
happen next and they don't know what
those opportunities might be for their
for their man their children and you
know what future might bring